nevada's democratic attorney general
aaron ford also weighed in on how the
election has been handled
and what voters should expect moving
forward 8 news now reporter kate houston
is over in our newsroom with what the
attorney general had to say
kate brian attorney general ford spoke
directly to voters during a facebook
live interview with battleborn progress
and he tried to reassure nevadans that
their votes will be counted
throughout the interview ford touched on
many different topics one issue brought
up multiple times was voter fraud
ford says there is simply no evidence of
voter fraud nor
obstruction of the observation of the
voting process here in nevada
now as for the time it takes to deliver
election results
ford reminded voters that many nevadans
took advantage of the vote by mail
process that paired with the safeguards
in place to prevent fraud
means it could take longer to receive
results
listen we knew that the process will
take time but this process is working
and instead of our election officials
receiving condemnation
over the consternation related to count
voting we should be giving them
commendations because they're working
very hard and doing their
very best to ensure that we have an
accurate count
attorney general aaron ford went on to
say that politicians will not decide who
wins this election
it's the american voters who will decide
he wants the will of the people in
nevada to speak for itself
now this conversation also touched on
the vote counting process
and how signatures are validated and you
can reach out to the clark county
elections department for more
information on that reporting from the
newsroom kate houston back to you